hey everybody welcome back to new
rockstars i'm marina mastros avengers
and games final battle is now something
we can re-watch over and over again
thanks to disney plus and literally do
nothing else with our lives not that
that's what i've been doing
which one is it but one interesting
thing that happens when cap uses thor's
hammer
is something that we all noticed but
something that we really didn't think
too
hard about now sure we all love when cap
proves himself worthy and saves thor
from getting stormbreaker shoved into
his chest by thanos ouchie but
cap catches the hammer and fights with
it yeah but he also summons
lightning even though he is 100 not the
god of thunder
technically he should only be able to
fight with the hammer and not summon
lightning right
so co-writer christopher marcus has
addressed this directly saying
there was certainly a debate at one
point because particularly in ragnarok
it establishes that thor
can summon lightning without the hammer
i think odin even says
it never was the hammer and yet cap
summons the lightning with the hammer
you get to those things and you're like
it's too awesome not to do it we'll talk
about it later
well christopher marcus now is later so
i'm going to talk about how the answer
to this mystery might be a
conspiracy the scene that marcus is
referring to is actually in thor
ragnarok hella has just turned thor into
a cyclops and when it looks like he's
about to have his ass handed to him
thor has a vision in a field with his
father odin odin gives him a verbal kick
in the pants saying
are you thor the god of hammers which is
a sick burn
that hammer was to help you control your
power to focus it
it's now your source of strength thor
then wakes up regroups and summons
lightning for the first time without his
hammer kicking everyone's ass
and proving that the power of lightning
exists within him not his tool so then
why is cap able to summon lightning with
thor's hammer too
really he should just be able to smash
things really hard maybe cap
is sort of like odin's adopted son and
odin has a real
soft spot for the guy especially
considering that cap is clearly actually
worthy of wielding the hammer maybe owen
lets cap
borrow some lightning from the afterlife
because these are special circumstances
you know like the end of a movie
franchise
maybe when hella shatters the hammer
back in ragnarok she also destroys the
charm that odin placed on the hammer in
all realities not just the one that ends
up occurring in end game admittedly
this doesn't make a ton of sense but
it's magic so who knows how it could
work
the simplest explanation might be that
when thor is incapacitated like having
have an
ax in his chest all his powers pass on
to the next person who is
also worthy in this case it's capped
just like ragnarok isn't a place it's a
people
maybe god of thunder isn't so much one
specific person as much as it is a title
that's passed on from worthy hero to
worthy hero
maybe it's like buffy where there's
always at least one slayer this could
also be the logic of how thor's power
will be passed on to jane foster in the
upcoming thor love and thunder how is
jane able to lift mjolnir maybe she is
the next worthy hero
of that movie and she gains thor's god
of thunder powers
you know like buffy but here's what i
think might actually be going on and
it's kind of fun okay so odin has
definitely lied in the past and
obviously has a lot of secrets what if
during thor's vision odin lied to him
what if odin was actually the one
summoning the lightning for thor but he
just told his son that he was the one
doing it
to get him off his viking butt this
concept will be important later what if
odin has still
more secrets that he took with him to
the grave what if those secrets are
wrapped up in his long gray old man hair
because let's be honest that scene in
ragnarok brings up a lot of questions
like
why did odin wait to give his kid a pep
talk until after he had already lost an
eye since odin has an eye patch does his
kid really need to have an eye patch as
well
is odin that insecure or does he really
just like the whole pirate look
it's worth noting that we don't actually
see cap lift up thor's hammer we see it
move
fly through the air bash thanos on the
head and then fly back to be
caught by cap one could argue that they
kept it as a close-up on the hammer to
enhance the mystery of who is actually
moving it what if and this is the fun
part in a sad
dark moment captain america has his own
vision experience with odin on the
battlefield
time is frozen odin lifts the hammer
hands it to cap and explains to him
i need you to save my son take this
hammer because
you've always been worthy of it as
you've known and use my boy's powers to
save him
because you're brothers okay i'm just
kidding about that last part but what if
what if odin is the one who throws the
hammer at thanos's head
essentially teaching cap how to use it
to cap it looks like odin is standing on
the battlefield he throws the hammer and
when it flies back
cap is standing in his place and he's
the one who catches it then
just like thor cap summons lightning and
beats thanos's ass with it
you know at least for a while to be fair
i'm probably not right about any of this
but it's very fun to guess
and maybe just maybe odin was
manipulating everything through the
course of a bunch of different movies
including ones he wasn't even in
now that would be a 10 conspiracy
why do you think cap was able to summon
lightning tell us down in the comments
and don't forget to hit subscribe follow
me on twitter marina mastros and thanks
for watching bye
i have to go find an eye patch and make
it fashion
[Music]
you